I saw inception
so let's just face it we are in a year
of crap 2010 has had some very good
movies shutter island' Toy Story 3 and
even some surprises The Karate Kid no
one expected that movie to be good but
overall this year has been disappointing
to the point where I just keep leaving
the theater like why you know like I go
to see a movie I'm like this one's gonna
be it
never mind I was like last airbender you
can do it sham lon nothing Robin Hood
it's gonna be great
boring I'm gonna be the point where I'm
like why why am i doing this why am I
going to these movies enter inception
directed by Christopher Nolan director
of following memento insomnia Batman
Begins The Prestige The Dark Knight his
new movie is called inception it's this
grand original story Inception takes
place in a futuristic world where people
are able to transmit themselves into
people's dreams to extract information
from those dreams no spoilers so enjoy
this review because no spoilers I never
do that there's one big job that
Leonardo DiCaprio who is known as the
extractor has to take in order to get
his life back so him Joseph
gordon-levitt Ellen Page Ken Watanabe
Killian Murphy what's that guy's name
but he's the awesome in it as I
explained the plot to you I'm trying
very hard to withhold something and what
that is this is one of the greatest
always have ever seen in my entire life
it is most definitely the best movie
I've seen so far this year and
Christopher Nolan has finally finally
made a movie that delivered people's
expectations and exceeded them I have
been seeing so many movies this year I'm
just like oh my gosh why am I going to
movies like this this movie reminds me
why I go to movies that this movie just
has everything the acting in this film
is excellent Leonardo DiCaprio as usual
who is very underrated in my opinion is
so so good in this movie I'm telling you
guys I've told you this before I've said
this before Joseph gordon-levitt is the
next big thing the dude is awesome 500
days of summer was
right and this movie proves that he has
in a whole nother side to him an action
hero sense to him that I just dug like
so intensely in this movie I was geeking
out during this movie I'm not gonna give
you any spoilers but there was a scene
in this movie where I was seeing the
theater and I was just like how I wanted
to go like ah but I knew that everyone
around me would be like dude what's your
problem
I just been seeing so many movies this
year where I'm just so disappointed
finally one is coming out it's good and
it's so good I need to calm down
I can't I
I've liked every single movie
Christopher Nolan has directed I had not
seen following but I've stayed memento
through now inception every single one
of them is good the guy is a beast he is
pretty much the greatest filmmaker
working nowadays Steven Spielberg is
amazing he is fantastic however he's
still my favorite director because
simply because Steven Spielberg has been
making movies for like three decades or
something for decades and Christopher
Nolan has yet to make a bad movie
besides the point everything about this
movie works the writing is just
brilliant it is one of the most original
movies I've ever seen in my life finally
a movie where from scene to scene I
don't know what's gonna happen I'm it's
just boom there it is I'm gonna expect
that at all I'm telling you now
inception finally delivers it some you
know I mean we've all been looking
forward to a movie and this is the kind
of movie that can break a person spirits
because I've told myself this movie
stinks I don't know what I'm gonna do
I'm seated like I don't know I'm just so
happy to tell you that everything in
this movie works the score Hans Zimmer
oh he's so good this movie is going to
be a science fiction classic 20 years
from now they're going to be like
Inception that movie is a classic a lot
of people are saying this think of a
matrix James Bond whips together and
made better
I don't over hype this but I'm I suggest
that all of you see inception now just
make plans today to see it and then go
see it again because you're going to
want to see it again
not because it's too confusing because
that is something that critics are
complaining whether saying oh it's too
confusing blah blah blah you know what
if your professional paid movie critic
you should know better you should know
that when you're seeing in a movie
theater you're supposed to pay attention
to movies you're not supposed to just
sit there and have it all just spread
Fred threw you through like an IV or
something all this and critics they go
to movies that are predictable and they
complain about the fact that it's
predictable now they see inception logo
it's confusing owners there but you know
what maybe you should look at that
paycheck next time you get it because I
don't get paychecks for this and I
understood this movie seriously any
critic who says this movie is bad I
don't trust you anymore
fury the film fan had a quote on his
Facebook he said Inception is the movie
that's going to bring out the trolls and
I completely agree with them inception
is the kind of movie that it's going to
bring out critics who should not be
getting paid for what they do or
somebody who's just a troll like Arman
white of course did not like Inception
as usual what do you know I'd never
dragged the visuals are stunning they
are absolutely stunning it's like
Christopher Nolan's sat down and when
you know what I think this scene is very
good but it needs to have something more
how about we have them floating in
mid-air yes that's the ticket that's the
spot right there what having floating
and that'll make it better because
that's what the people if I ever meet
Christopher Nolan I'm just going to give
him like a humungous man hug with all
good intentions of course because the
man can make a movie I'm telling you now
go see inception so good the best movie
of the year four out of four stars if I
had a higher rating it would get
inception meets all expectations exceeds
expectations everything about this movie
is amazing it has classic written all
over an Academy I'm telling you if you
don't nominate this movie like you
didn't nominate the Dark Knight I am
never watching the Academy Awards again